louise pour tous se demandent c'est un
député par le passé ayant déjà touché
une prime de départ peut toucher une
nouvelle fois cette même prime de départ
s'il tire à nouveau l'assemblée
nationale la réponse est oui cette prime
de départ qui est en fait une allocation
de transition peut être touché une
deuxième fois par un député selon
plusieurs cas de figure premièrement
s'il est défait lors d'une élection
évidemment deuxièmement s'il décide à la
fin de son mandat de ne pas se
représenter ou encore si en cours de
mandat il décide de démissionner mais
dans ce cas de figure précis il doit
motiver doivent justifier sa décision et
c'est un commissaire à l'éthique et à la
déontologie qui tranchera qui prendra
donc sa décision de verser donc cette
allocation de transition car dans la loi
québécoise
il n'y a aucune interdiction de verser
plusieurs fois cette allocation de
transition
si vous avez d'autres questions sur les
élections québécoises n'hésitez pas à
nous écrire vos élections at radio tirer
canada.ca